this week at t and verizon agreed to a
request from u.s transportation
secretary pete boudej for a voluntary
two-week delay of their 5g rollouts on
c-band frequencies
the c-band is often called the
goldilocks frequency a sweet spot that
delivers both lightning fast speed and
relatively wide coverage
the two telecom giants have collectively
spent 67 billion dollars on c-band
licenses and had planned to launch new
5g servers on wednesday in many u.s
cities the impending national rollout of
5g on the c-ban has turned into a turf
war between two powerful government
agencies both the fcc which governs the
electromagnetic spectrum and the faa
which governs aviation safety say 5g and
safe air travel can co-exist but are at
odds on exactly how the aviation
industry has pointed out for several
years that aircraft radio altimeters
operate on c-band frequencies altimeters
measure the distance between a plane and
the ground they're crucial for landing
aircraft in low visibility conditions
like heavy fog snow and rain on december
30th airlines for america a trade group
representing the airline industry filed
an emergency petition asking regulators
to temporarily block at teen verizon's
deployment on the spectrum the petition
cited an airworthiness directive issued
earlier this month by the faa which
deemed it unsafe to rely on cockpit
safety systems in the presence of 5g
transmitters in the c-band a report by
the non-profit radio technical
commission for aeronauticism which was
used in the air worthiness directive by
the faa says quote the results of the
study performed clearly indicate that
this risk is widespread and has the
potential for broad impacts to aviation
operations in the united states
including the possibility of
catastrophic failures leading to
multiple fatalities in the absence of
appropriate mitigations but the telecoms
industry doesn't buy it earlier this
year in an op-ed for morning consult
meredith atwell baker the president of
the trade group representing the
wireless companies called 5g and airline
safety the faa's false choice
baker notes that no fatalities involving
planes in 5g have occurred in any of the
almost 40 countries currently utilizing
the c-ban for 5g purposes but the faa
counters that other countries have
implemented mitigations such as lower
power levels around airports canada for
example has restricted c-band use near
airports the decision by at team verizon
to agree to a delay kicks the can down
the road for another two weeks to
january 19th but 5g could be one more
issue airlines and air travelers will
have to deal with in 2022
you